el primer ministro del reino unido boris
johnson se prepara para masajes acción
política en cualquier momento se
conocerán los resultados de una
investigación sobre las denuncias de
fiesta en su oficina y residencia cuando
estaban prohibidas por el cubil 19
conocido como el informe su grey lleva
el nombre de la alta funcionaria
encargada de la investigación
independiente se trata de una antigua
directora general de propiedad y ética
del gobierno que ya ha dirigido
investigaciones de alto nivel el jueves
johnson seguro que no se interponga en
el camino del informe hoy está
retrasando el informe de su grave servir
y no por supuesto que no pero me temo
que hay que dejar que las
investigaciones independientes sigan
adelante pendientes en jardines cabo lo
publicará en su totalidad por supuesto
el llamado escándalo del parche gheit ha
golpeado la popularidad de johnson y
dependiendo de si se descubren
infracciones contra el reglamento kobe
el informe grave podría ayudarle a poner
fin a semanas de escándalo o acabar su
tiempo en el cargo abruptamente la
policía británica abrió su propia en el
martes pero si decidió que la
investigación de greg no interferiría le
hizo la policía está plenamente
capacitada para llevar a cabo
investigaciones son operativamente
independientes necesitamos ver el
resultado de su investigación como
también necesitamos ver el resultado del
informe de subgrupos se espera que greg
envíe un informe completo a la oficina
de johnson de forma inminente y que
downing street- lo publique unas horas
después el líder conservador acudirá
entonces al parlamento para hacer una
declaración